ونحييكم متابعينا من جديد حرك جمهوري ضد
رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في التعامل مع عدد
من القضايا والملفات ابرزها ازمه وباء
كورونا وملفه المهاجرين الجمهوريون باشروا
بفتح ملف الهجره غير الشرعيه الرسميه في
كونجرس من خلال عقد جلسه استماع هي الاولى
حول الملف منذ تسلمهم للاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب الجمهوريون مشاهدينا يتهمون اداره
بايدن بخلق ازمه على الحدود مع المكسيك
وهي يتحدثون عن عمليات تسلل وتدفق
المخدرات عبر الحدود كما فتح الجمهوريون
جبهه اخرى ضد اداره بايدن حول سياسه
الاداره في التعاطي مع وبائي كورونا
وعقدت لجنه او عقدت لجنه المراقبه
والاصلاح الحكومي جلسه استماع بعنوان
المصاريف الفيدراليه للوباء حيث يقول
الجمهوريون ان مليارات الدولارات تم هدرها
في برنامج
متعلق بكوفيد 19
الجمهوريون في مواجهه اداره بايدن ملفات
وقضايا يستغلها الجمهوريون للضيق على
بايدن منها العثور على وثائق سريه في منزل
بايدن ومكتبه السابق تورط نجل الرئيس
هانتر في قضايا فساد التعامل مع ازمه وباء
كورونا التعامل مع ازمه المهاجرين
الانسحاب الفوضوي للقوات الامريكيه من
افغانستان
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن طارق
شاميه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن
دائما عبر سكاي بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اهلا بكم ضيفاي اسم حالي ان ابدا
مع الاستاذه جرار البعض يقول بان بيض لا
يحسد في هذه المرحله
اليوم تفتح ملفات جديده ملف الهجره وباء
كورونا بعد فتح ملفات كالانسحاب من
افغانستان هانتر بايدن وملف
الخروقات الماليه وكذلك الملف وثائق
الوثائق الرسميه ملف مهم جدا ما الذي
يريده الجمهوريون هل انهم لم يتمكنوا من
عزله او من طرح هذه الفكره فيريدون
التضييق عليه
شكرا لك لدعوه الكريمه بعيده الضيف الكريم
واقول انه بلغ الامر حد التعاطف ولا يقصد
قطعا ولكن هناك ثمه التعاطف لانه في وضع
مربك ليس فقط لادارته وانما مربك للحزب
الديمقراطي برمته بكل الاتجاهات والتيارات
التي توجد في هذا الحزب الذي قام في
انتخاب التنصيب نذكر قبل عامين بانه هو
الحزب الديمقراطي قال انه يمثل واستطاع ان
يوحد الحزب الديمقراطي واوصله الى البيت
الابيض الان الانتخابات مجلس النواب
الامريكي وخسارته لهذا المنبر الهام يشير
النهج الذي ينتهج اليمين في الحزب
الجمهوري ان هذه التحقيقات يراد بها واجيب
هنا على التساؤل الذي طرحتموه
الهدف هو ايرباكو وتسجيل المزيد من
الاهداف الانتخابيه في مرماه مرمى الاداره
ومرمى الحزب لان
هذه التحقيقات هي في الاساس في المقام
الاول تحقيقات السياسيه المقصود بها ان
يكون هناك اكبر عدد من المشاهده كجماهير
يعني الجمهور الامريكي ان يتابع هذه
التحقيقات ومن ثم تتفاعل هذه الاراء
وتتحول الى مواقف خاصه في الولايات
المتارجحه والاصوات المستقله حتى يرى
المواطن الامريكي وهنا اختم في هذه الجمله
كيف اثرت اداره بايدن على مصالح المصالح
الفرديه للاسره الامريكيه في قضيه كورونا
هذا الفساد المال الضخم الذي الان يكشف
عنه هذه الاموال لو ضخت في اماكن افضل
كانت النتيجه افضل عن مواطن الامريكي الذي
يعاني الان بارتفاع فاتوره التدفئه
الان نتحدث عن مليارات تهدر في اوكرانيا
وايضا يبدو ان هناك مليارات اهدرت على
الملف المهم الذي عطل حياه الامريكيين
واثرها على امريكيه في المقام الاول وهو
كورونا استاذ طارق اذا ما اشرنا الى ان
لكل رئيس في الواقع فواته لكل فتره رئاسيه
مخالفاتها طبعا مع يعني
نسب متباينه او مستويات متباينه هل كل هذه
الملفات تفتح بهذه الطريقه ويتحمل بايدن
مسؤوليتها هل هناك مبالغه او ان الرجل
يعني قدم اسوا مع عنده في فتره توليه
الرئاسه وهذه الملفات تعتبر حقيقه ازمات
متتاليه
تحياتي لك اولا
يعني بدايه بالتاكيد هناك مبالغات كثيره
جدا وهو اعتقد ان ما يحدث من مجلس النواب
الذي يقوده الجمهوريون بفارق ضئيل للغايه
جدا هو نوع من المسرح السياسي الذي يستهدف
يعني اثاره مزيد من قلق الامريكيين حول
مستقبلهم وبالتالي يخصم من رصيد
الديمقراطيين والرئيس بايدن خلال
الانتخابات المقبله العامه سواء كانت على
المستوى الرئاسي او مستوى مجلسي الشيوخ
والنواب لكن الى اين ستصل هذه النتيجه لا
اعتقد انها ستصل في كل الملفات صحيح ان
بعض الملفات قد يكون لها تاثير من حيث
يعني
اثاره الجدل حول بعض القضايا حول بعض
الملفات حول ربما هانتر بيضا على وجه
الخصوص
ولا احد يدافع عنه بشكل كبير لانه ربما
ملطخا بالفساد لكن في نفس الوقت هذا لا
يوجد دليل قاطع حتى الان والا كان كل
التقدم به على ان الرئيس متورط في هذه
المساله والمساله مفتوحه وسوف تستغرق مزيد
من التحقيقات ومزيد من الوقت اما بالنسبه
هو يعني بكل تاكيد الاداره الحاليه نجحت
في تحقيق ما استهدفته وهو وجود شبكه امان
اقتصاديه للفئات المهمشه التي لم تكن
تستطيع الذهاب الى المستشفى ولكن اسمحلي
يا استاذه طارق الاستاذ بشار منذ قليل
تحدث بخصوص ملف كورونا عن ملفات فساد
لا يوجد دليل على ان هناك ملفات فساد حتى
الان هناك تحقيقات نعم لكن ما هي الملفات
الفساد هذا ما يدعيه ويزعمه لجمهوريون لكن
لا يوجد حتى الان دليل واضح على ان هناك
ملف فساد والا فليتقدموا الى المحاكم
لمحاكمه المسؤول عن ذلك لكن من الذي اقصى
بالجمهوريين وافشل ترامب في الانتخابات
السابقه هو ملف كوفيد لانه فشل في كيفيه
اداره الازمه وكان يدلي بتصريحات يعني لا
علاقه لها بالطب وبالصحه العامه وكانت
هناك انتقادات واسعه حتى من قبل
الجمهوريين انفسهم اما بالنسبه للجمهوريين
ايضا منقسمون في ملفات كثيره بما فيها ملف
الهجره كانت هناك انقسامات مؤخرا وهناك
مشروع تقدم به عدد من النواب اليمنيين في
مجلس النواب واعترض نواب اخرون وقال ان
هذا يتصادم مع فكره الولايات المتحده في
بعض القضايا فيما يخص قضايا الهجره
وبالتالي
مهما تكون صحيح هناك انقسمه داخل الحزبين
ولكن حضرتك تعتبر بان هناك
اقتبس او استعير منك التوصيف هناك مسرحيه
سياسيه او مسرح سياسي وبدع فيه الجمهوريون
ما رايك استاذ طارق ضيف يقول بان هذا
المسرح السياسي الذي يخلقه الجمهوريون
سيؤثر ولكن ليس بالدرجه التي يطمح لها
البشر الاستاذ بشار
اعتقد كما طارق اعتقد ان السؤال له هو
مصطلح باللغه الانجليزيه يستخدم هذا
السيركس اول ما عاش وهو الشعب الامريكي
وحتى صوره امريكا في الخارج هو السيركس
الذي قامت به
قامت في محاولتين متكررتين لعزل الرئيس
ترامب وتعطيله في كثير من التحقيقات التي
تبينت انها تجني وكان فيها الكثير من
انعدام المصداقيه اتضح الان في قضيه كوفيد
الذي يدع جانبا موضوع الفساد والفساد مهما
طال الزمن سيكشف ولكن هناك فضائح تم
تفجيرها في قضيه بانشا كوبت لماذا كان
هناك نوع من المحاوله للتعتيم على اصل هذا
الفيروس مخلقه بغير مقلق لماذا مثلا اضطر
مسؤولون في في
فايزر نقول صراحه بالاعتراف امام الات
الاوروبي امام البرلمان الاتحاد الاوروبي
في جلسه اوفر سايت ايضا للمراقبه اعترفوا
بانه لم تكن هناك خطوات شفافه ولا علميه
حتى في قضيه السماح للبكسيم ونشر بالطريقه
التي تمت فضائح كثيره طبيه وعلميا الان
يكشف عنها مرتبطه ايضا بالمحاولات التعتيم
التي تواطها بها للاسف السياسيون
واعلاميون ضللوا الراي العام تبين الان
انها كانت بالفعل مسرحيه كقضيه هانتر
بايدن الان هانتر بايدن يعترف الصحافه
امام الصحافه الراي العام الامريكي بان
اللاب توب هو له
هناك تفاصيل حتى اخرى ولكن لانه بقت
لدقيقه ونصف سانهيها معك استاذه طارق
لنفهم كيف تدار الامور في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كل هذه الملفات هل تضر
بالحزب ام انها سيقتصر ضررها فقط على
الشخص بان النخب الامريكي او المتابع يفصل
بين الشخص المتحمل المسؤوليه و هذا اتن من
حزب فكل الحزب سيدفع ثمن ربما في
الانتخابات القادمه
يعني السياسه المتحركه ومن الصعب الحكم
الان على ما سوف تصل اليه نتائج بعد عامين
هناك تاثير من البياسه سوف تجري في النهر
وهناك من الاتهامات المتبادله بين
الجانبين وايضا الجمهوريون هم محل اختبار
هم في مجلس النواب يجرون تحقيقات لكنهم في
النهايه لن يستطيعوا تمرير اي تشريعات او
قوانين بالنظر الى وجود السيطره
الديمقراطيين على مجلس الشيوخ ووجود رئيس
ايضا في السلطه وبالتالي سوف نشهد مزيد من
الجدل ومزيد من الاحترام ومن اللجان ايضا
هذا مجلس
ونحن سنتابع كل هذا طارق شامي الكاتب
المحلله السياسي ومن واشنطن دائما بشر
جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شكرا جزيلا
لكما